Speaker 1: Let's go next to Kevin from Virginia,
Kevin from Virginia.
You're on the air.
Speaker 4: Hello, David.
Hello.
I realize this is kind of old news at this
point, but I've been trying to call it the
last couple of weeks to talk about permanent
daylight saving time.
OK.
But I am on on the side of Permanent Standard
Time and I could go on a diatribe.
I personally think it's better, but I think
my best argument on the subject is more of
a historical one.
Hmm.
So my framing of this issue is if if we are
going to go to permanent daylight saving time,
but we're really doing is we're changing our
time zones by one time zone.
And you're kind of saying if you want to go
to permanent daylight saving time, you're
saying we got it wrong when we established
the time zones in the late 80s.
Or you think society has changed fundamentally
in that last hundred and fifty or so years,
but we all benefit from shifting our schedules
by one hour?
Sure.
And I just don't think that's I don't think
that's accurate.
I think it was a lot of thought put into the
time zones when they were established that
it lined up with solar time that we used for
millennia.
I don't think we should change that.
Speaker 1: So listen, I think that actually
society has changed dramatically since the
time zones were established by virtue of completely
ubiquitous electricity and artificial lighting,
I think.
I think that it has changed now.
That's not reason alone to say, let's do permanent
daylight saving now.
I lean towards permanent daylight saving.
You know why?
Because I don't get up early enough to care
about it being dark in the morning, and I
get a lot of benefit from it being light out
an additional hour in winter in the northeast,
in middle of December.
It's ugly.
It's depressing what goes on in the northeast?
Now that being said, I am sensitive to the
fact that, you know, if you look at the western
edge of certain time zones, like, for example,
if you look at Columbus, Ohio is an interesting
place in Columbus, Ohio, there on the western
edge of the Eastern Time zone.
If we were to do permanent daylight saving
time, if I understand correctly in December,
sunrise would be something like eight 20 in
Columbus.
I looked it up at one point I don't exactly
remember.
I agree that that's kind of complicated.
That's not so good.
So another idea I heard was split the difference
make a 30 minute adjustment and make that
permanent.
The problem is that then the difference between
our time zones and those in other parts of
the world are going to be, you know, six and
a half hours, eight and a half hours, which
is just very complicated.
So I don't know that there's a perfect solution.
I hate what we do now, and I lean towards
permanent daylight saving time.
Speaker 4: I also think what we do now.
Yeah, I personally, I think we need to be
taking a hard look at the schedule of the
business day schedule of schools.
You know, there's been a lot written about
school starting too early and the health impacts
that has on our children are absolutely going
with permanent daylight saving time.
We're kind of sidestepping the real issue.
But yeah, the
Speaker 1: security issue also, which is there
are other countries where it's much, much
more typical that the business and work day
starts at either 9:30 or 10:00 and goes till
more like six or seven.
And then, like in a lot of places in Europe,
you leave work at 7:00 and then you know,
you go right to drinks and then a later dinner.
Like when I was in Spain.
Now Spain maintains the siesta for a lot of
workers.
You open the store at 10:00 and then you're
off from one to three and then you're open
from three to seven.
And at 7:00, you go for a drink and at 9:30
you have dinner and it's just a totally different
lifestyle.
Now, culturally, I don't know that that will
work in the U.S., but there's many other configurations
of the daily schedule that could work.
Speaker 4: Well, I appreciate you talking
to me about this, I'll be curious to see if
it does get enacted permanently.
You still like it after your first winter
going through it because right now we know
what standard time is like in the winter and
we have some issues with that.
But unless we can remember back to 1974, we
don't really know what the warnings are like.
You know, winter with the team.
I think people, I'll
Speaker 1: sleep through it.
So I just don't know.
I mean, I'll be fine.
All right.
All right, Kevin, thank you.
I do care about that topic, actually.
I find it pretty, pretty interesting.
OK.
Let's go next to God.
I always struggle with this.
Alisa Medusa from Dallas.
Did I get it right this time?
Oh.
Speaker 5: Honestly, I'm giving you an A-plus
for that, because I could tell that you've
been putting in the practice, and I really
do appreciate it.
Speaker 1: My pleasure.
Do you do most people just call you?
Oh.
Speaker 5: Oh, yeah, because I mean, they
have the same issue with butchering my name.
OK, so I mean, it's because like my parents
are from Nigeria.
Yeah, I was born here, so you'd have to blame
my mom for that.
Speaker 1: Fair.
Well, let's we'll do that on a different episode.
Speaker 5: Yeah, so again, thank you so much
for taking my call.
Today, I wanted to talk about something different.
And it's in regards to food and I mean, I
know it's not a very attractive topic topic
to be talking about, given how we're talking
about Ukraine, Trump and Biden.
But I feel like food is a big issue.
They're not a big issue, but like obesity
in general in the United States is obviously
a very concerning issue that not enough people
are talking about.
And I feel like, you know, most of it stems
from, you know, our poor guidance and education
on food in general.
Like the good example of this is the first
aid pyramid that came out and like I think
the 80s for the United States, where, you
know, the very bottom of the food pyramid
said that we should have six to 11 servings
of bread pasta.
Right?
But like less servings of vegetables and fruit?
Yep.
I mean, I have no idea how that makes sense
whatsoever, but I also know that, you know,
unfortunately, big food, a.k.a.
the food lobby, you know, they were, you know,
pressuring, you know, the USDA a lot in terms
of, you know, making sure that they would
be able to like, push their products.
So I know I kind of went all over the place
with this, but I guess my question is, what
do you think that like we could do to, you
know, combat this issue with obesity?
And I guess, you know, yeah, like what do
you think that we could do?
Speaker 1: It's such a big topic.
I mean, there's so many issues here and oh
man, and it also gets very touchy politically
to talk about obesity.
One of the there's a bunch of different things
here.
First of all, of course, there's an educational
aspect to it where a lot of people have been
given bad information or no information about,
you know, what it actually means to eat like
a healthy, balanced diet.
Number two, you look at marketing and the
way that marketing for food products, not
for ingredients, for food products, because
that's what they are, steers people towards
unhealthy food.
I mean, most of the food that's marketed is
not healthy because just basic ingredients
don't really need marketing.
I mean, OK, like you'll see like avocados
in general advertised or sometimes like milk
generally.
But for the most part, the advertising is
for finished food products.
You then see the financial incentive where,
you know, just growing corn.
It's like, OK, it's just corn, and that's
what it is.
But if you can separate corn into 10 different
products and then use them as additives and
bump up up above, you can generate more profit.
But you're also giving people extremely processed
items habits that are set by parents for young
kids and the age at which, you know, kids
start having juice and soda and candy and
this type of thing.
There's so many different things here that
it is just a massive problem to get our head
around, and there's no there's no easy solution
at this point.
Speaker 5: Yeah, I totally understand, and
one book that I've been like, you know, looking
into reading, it's called food politics.
I'm not sure if you're familiar with the book,
but I'm probably going to pick up the book
sometime soon to get a better understanding
of that.
But yeah, thank you so much for taking my
call and really quick special shout out to
David Pepper.
Really good interview that you did with them.
I actually know him.
Not like super personally, but I've met him
on campus at the University of Cincinnati,
so I was like, really shocked to see you like
David and David interviewing each other.
So again, thank you so much for everything
that you do.
And again, good interview and I hope to talk
to you soon.
Speaker 1: All right, sounds good.
Thanks for the call.
Always great to hear from.
Oh, let's talk to Brian from Eastern Shore,
Maryland.
Not a place I've heard of before, Brian.
Brian, you're on the air.
You've got to unmute in order to talk to me,
though.
Now, boy.
That's too bad.
Things were going so well, they really were.
I guess, no, no, Brian, there.